[Music]
well hey there I'm back today with
another reaction video which is where I
react to videos that were submitted by
you the viewer today we're going to pick
back up where we left off in part one of
a previous video from Matt Whitman of
the 10-minute Bible Hour a few years ago
he sat down with three sdas to learn
about SDA theology like we saw in part
one it has been well interesting if you
missed that part the link to it is in
the description box down below but
before we get back into it I want to
remind you all that answering adventism
is a viewer supported Ministry that is
equipping as many Christians as possible
to reach as many 7th Day Adventists as
possible with the true Christ in his
gospel if you like what we're doing here
and you'd like to see more of that
please consider partnering with us at
answering adventism tocom donate it is
through the support of our partners and
YouTube members that we are able to
fulfill our mission so thank you so much
for your support now last time we left
off right before they transitioned into
talking about the Adventist Heavenly
Trio what they call the Trinity and
Ellen White I'm sure this will be
interesting my understanding is that at
least during part of that time you guys
were not
trinitarian but you definitely are now
yeah when did that all part of that
course of study it was a deep our
Biblical Scholars just started pouring
Through the Bible and started looking at
everything and said you know
what we really need to believe in the
Trinity this is truly what the Bible the
Bible says so in 1863 when this thing
launches it launches as a trinitarian
Christian denomination there was still
formation that was going on until until
later like 15 20 years probably and I
could I I wish I could give you an exact
date on that it took time some of the
the well-known Adventists and some of
some of people who I would say were
Adventist Founders people um like Joseph
Bates um they they they didn't have what
was what would be identified as a as a a
true trinitarian concept um it was there
was a sense that the founders of the
church didn't feel like that that was
something they needed to confront dead
on and obviously we we sit around this
table right now and go well yeah
trinitarian understanding of of
scripture is like this is core to our
you to our understanding all right so a
bit of a quick stop here but this was
not true it can't be core to your
understanding when it's still being
ironed out in the 20th century trying to
retrofit a new belief into the system
which is what was done has only created
more problems for the division in the
movement it's why you have anti-
Heavenly Trio people that are getting
more and more vocal within the movement
especially online saying the modern
movement has apostatized and it needs to
return to the roots of the Pioneers now
I cite Jerry Moon's paper the Quest for
a Biblical Trinity a lot there's a
reason for that it is a scholarly work
on the historical development of the SDA
belief of God in their system moon is
the chair of church history at the SDA
seminary in Michigan qualified
individual on the subject notice what he
says influen their doctrinal development
in this area quote the change from
Adventist rejection of the traditional
doctrine of the Trinity to acceptance of
a Biblical trinitarian Doctrine was not
a simple reversal when James White
denounced Credo trinitarianism in 1846
Ellen White agreed with both his
positive point that the father and the
son are two distinct literal tangible
persons and his negative point that the
philosophical trinitarianism held by
many did spiritualize away the personal
reality of the father father and the son
soon after this she added the conviction
based on visions that both Christ and
the father have bodily form rejecting
the teaching of one trinitarian Creed
that God is without body or Parts close
quote so the Adventist teaching is not
Orthodox trinitarianism and their belief
was informed based on
what visions and you'll notice he
contrasts what Christians believe over
and against what the SDA Church teaches
referring to their God concept as
biblical because they believe their gods
all have physical tangible form like
humans do further evidencing that this
is not the Christian God and did you
notice that the guy with the glasses
said that the Pioneers didn't have what
a true
trinitarian
concept this is exactly what I mean by
having to scale the language barrier
with this movement because this is the
exact language that Jerry Moon uses in
his paper to to say that it can hardly
be denied that Ellen White held to a
trinitarian concept first he writes
quote in previous research I have traced
the development of the avenus doctrine
of God from opposition to the Trinity
Doctrine as traditionally formulated to
acceptance of the biblical concept of
one God in three persons I've also
traced the clear progression in Ellen
White's Visions from 1850 onward showing
that her Visions gradually formed her
concept of God until by 189 8 when she
published Desire of Ages she held a
trinitarian concept close quote Yeah
there aren't various concepts of the
Trinity he is positing a sort of social
trinitarianism here a watering down of
the teaching which is very specific
making it generalized and then claiming
well because we use the same words and
fundamentally say three in one that
means we are trinitarians which is
exactly what he later goes on to also
write quote since enen white clearly
held the basic formula of one God in
three persons it can hardly be denied
that her view is essentially trinitarian
however her view differs from
traditional trinitarianism in the
following important respects close quote
he then goes on to list a large number
of reasons why their belief is not the
same as what Christians believe that's
what beard glasses guy means by
eventually they embraced a trinitarian
concept and it was ultimately based on
Visions like Moon plainly said
yet the gray-haired glasses guy didn't
tell you that part it's just that they
studied the bible really really hard and
that's it the closest the SDA church can
claim to being trinitarian is that their
Heavenly Trio is a form of social
trinitarianism like I said go look up
what that is if you do not know but it
must be said boldly and sincerely not to
simply be
inflammatory the Adventist Church is not
a part of the body of Christ it is not
Christian they have a different God
Adventists hate when I say this but it's
the facts and people need to know this
it is no different than how Mormons have
a false god or false gods Jehovah's
Witnesses have a false god Hindus have
false gods Islam has a false god and so
on it doesn't matter if you use all the
right
words what you're actually fundamentally
meaning and saying by those words is
what matters and when you pop the hood
of the car on this movement you find
it's a lemon it's not good it is
rotten hijacking the word Trinity
redefining it but then insisting to the
people you took it from that you mean
the same thing is dishonest it's not
Christlike the administ church needs to
own that they have their own unique
belief and God concept that is
ultimately informed by the great
controversy Paradigm which Christians do
not uphold and they need to be
forthright about this and defend it not
try and make inroads with Christians and
insist you mean the same thing when the
scholarship is literally on record
outright contrasting the belief against
what Christians
believe and don't get me wrong I want
Adventists to become Christians that's
why I say this they need to be warned
that this movement is cursed by God for
having a false gospel that it's not from
him Satan is the architect and Jesus
cares about them enough to send people
to warn them of this deception Ellen
White Ellen G white is that
right who is she and where does she fit
into the equation Ellen White during the
time of the great disappointment was
just a teenager someone who was caught
up in the movement Ellen Harmon was her
she wasn't even Ellen White at the time
yeah and uh she would later go on to be
one of the major founders of our
denomination uh we hold a position that
she had the prophetic had a prophetic
gift and so as such we we highly value
Her counsel and her writings and her
input on theological
matters yeah Justin that was a clever
way of stating what the official
position is it has become almost a
weekly Occurrence at this point but he
here we are back at the SDA Church's
official statement of confidence in the
writings of Ellen White wherein they
state that Ellen White's writings are
divinely inspired they correct
inaccurate interpretations of scripture
and they uplift the normative character
of it meaning they allow one to see what
scripture is really saying in other
words she is the infallible interpreter
and this statement is put out by the
general conference in session who Ellen
White claimed that when in session they
are God's highest Authority on Earth and
when a decision comes down down from
them private opinions and beliefs are to
be yielded to them that would include
these gentlemen including Justin coup
and to not do so would be considered a
sin and Rebellion to God which would
mean they're not fitted for heaven in
their system and hopefully they've come
around to being more forthright and
eager to share this belief more clearly
and unashamedly not give the watered
down plausibly deniable answer Ellen
White wasn't just a founding member of
the SDA movement and she didn't simply
have the gift of Prophecy as most
charismatic Christians would understand
in including even Christians who are not
charismatics when they hear gift of
Prophecy they're not going to think what
the SDA church is saying about Ellen
White Ellen functioned as the movement's
stamp of approval from God that they
were correct in their understandings of
various doctrines notice what the LG
white estate says in the preface of her
book early writings they start by
quoting her and they say quote during
this whole time I could not understand
the reasoning of the Brethren my mind
was locked as it were and I could not
comprehend the meaning of the scriptures
we were studying this was one of the
greatest Sorrows of my life I was in
this condition of mind until all the
principal points of our faith were made
clear to our minds in harmony with the
word of God the Brethren knew that when
not in Vision I could not understand
these matters and they accepted as light
direct from Heaven the revelations given
thus the doctrinal foundation of the
Seventh Adventist Church was laid in the
faithful study of the word of God and
when the Pioneers could not make Headway
white was given light that helped to
explain their difficulty and opened the
way for the study to continue the
Visions also placed the stamp of God's
approval upon correct conclusions thus
the prophetic gift acted as a corrector
of error and a confirmer of Truth close
quote this is to say that Ellen by her
own admission could not understand what
was being said when the men would be
studying the Bible at certain points the
men would come to disagreements and
Ellen would then supposedly be given
light from Heaven AKA Visions which
would give the stamp of approval from
God along with countless details not
found in the Bible that allegedly help
enhance it thus she allegedly acted as a
corrector of error and confirmer of
Truth spoiler alert no Ellen didn't
function as a corrector of error she was
the source of much confusion for the
movement and is still a source of such I
also want to note that Justin said they
believe she had the prophetic gifting so
remember this whenever you hear an
Adventist try and tell you no no no
Ellen White never claimed to be a
Prophet this is an argument that's often
employed by some to try and get out of
having to defend and uphold her as such
but as Justin stated though very
innocuously the organization does not
take that position and she is codified
as such in the fundamental beliefs yes
individual Adventists might disagree
with this many of them do but that's the
official position of the organization
whether they like that or not but now
that they're getting into Ellen White I
am curious to see where this goes did
she predict more dates I mean what kind
of prophecies would she she throwing out
is it that's that's throwing out that
that sounded so disrespectful that's not
how I meant that to sound but I mean
what sort of prophecies was commun thank
you I didn't like the way it sounded
actually I'm glad you mentioned it
because uh it's an opportunity for us to
clear up misconception and one of the
misconceptions that a lot of people have
is that that Adventist predicted Seventh
Day Adventist predicted the end of the
world in 1844 and we've already said
like the church didn't even exist at
that point in time we we we experienced
the great disappointment that was a
millerite prediction it was AER
prediction and I'm not throwing him
under the bus like he was a he was a
good man who believed very sincerely and
you know um I'm tempted to yeah I mean
he predicted he he thought he could be
the one who knew the day or the hour he
threw out a prediction that just like
everybody else who's predicted it didn't
happen and he was and he by the way so
so I as a Christian I I do have a bit of
a problem with that practice there's a
lot of other misconceptions that that
and this is an opportunity to clear one
of them up is that Adventist have been
date setters and there there actually
weren't other dates that's the only one
that's been thrown out by millerites but
I'm and even so you guys have said no
dates none yeah since 1863 and and I'm
not dodging that I'm just like saying
Miller had actually said initially he
had said like sometime around the fall
of
1843 so there was when I say that there
was another date it was there was not
another date that I'm aware of after
October 22 1844 and Adventists have not
Ellen White Never predicted the the the
second coming on a day or those kind of
things yeah this is simply not true and
I'll explain how but first what did I
say back in part one distancing
themselves from the Forgotten years and
I get it gentlemen I get it as an
Adventist I didn't want to be associated
with that mess either but this is just
smoke and mirrors it doesn't matter if
the organization hadn't formally
Incorporated until 1863 this is because
they were against such an idea
originally not because they weren't
already organized
that was allegedly part of the problem
that the Pioneers had with Protestants
was them being organized the way they
were we're never going to be a
denomination these guys coming out of
the Christian connection which was also
against such a thing but the Pioneers
also didn't believe that they'd even be
here for much longer and saw no need to
incorporate they very clearly did not
imagine their movement existing for 180
years but acting like there were only
failed predictions with Miller is
another attempt to like obscure or
rewrite history just like rebranding
William Miller as an American reformer
but notice glass's beard guy was quick
to say that the SDA church has set zero
dates at least that he's aware of here's
the problem with this claim did Alan
white formally set a date that she came
up with no but remember how they claim
she functions for the movement stamp of
approval from God light from Heaven AKA
Visions well she gave the stamp of
approval on a number of individuals in
their movement that did set false dates
and I can't stand when some Adventist
try and play word games on this she
didn't set a single date right she just
claimed to hear from God that dates
other people set were correct and they
weren't which is actually more
problematic it was being circulated in
their movement that Jesus would return
in 1849 without getting into the weeds
around all the false date setting
leading up to 1851 Ellen had already
received a number of other Visions at
this point which allegedly let them know
why exactly Jesus hadn't returned yet in
1849 when they were sure Jesus would
return that year she claimed quote I saw
some looking too far off for the coming
of the Lord time has continued on a few
years longer than they expected
therefore they think it may continue a
few years more and in this way their
minds are being led from present truth
out after the world in these things I
saw great danger for if the mind is
filled with other things present truth
is shut out and there's no place in our
foreheads for the Seal of the Living God
the seal is the Sabbath I saw that the
time for Jesus to be in the most holy
place was nearly finished and that time
can last but a very little longer and
what leisure time we have should be
spent in searching the Bible which is to
judge us in the last days close quote so
she saw people were looking too far off
for what coming of the Lord this is it
to say that in 1849 Ellen White
allegedly received a vision confirming
that people who thought time would
continue on a few more years were wrong
and the time for Jesus in the most holy
place was nearly finished and he was
about to return probation was going to
close and the time of trouble was going
to allegedly begin that year we saw that
in part one we saw how James White was
teaching that it was present truth in
1849 for Adventists to believe that the
time of trouble would come upon them
that year because they were living just
before the close of time and it's also
why in the same Year Ellen White was
telling people that she was shown by God
that the followers of the movement
needed to sell their possessions and
give the proceeds to the movement
because they wouldn't need them when the
time of Trouble Comes because they might
clog them down so just like James this
was allegedly going to begin the time of
trouble that year and she was shown by
God that those who rejected this truth
were in great Danger
this little band of early 7th Day
Adventists because that's what they were
despite not having a formal registered
Corporation the little
flock they were teaching with Divine
Authority that rejecting a false vision
and prophecy put one in great danger
this is the same Prophet that gets
codified in the SDA fundamental beliefs
we're supposed to believe that all that
stuff doesn't matter because it happened
before a corporate entity was registered
in 1863 with the name sth Day Adventist
Church nope not going to work she was a
false prophet and she doesn't have some
pre1 1863 Immunity on that and there's a
lot more than just this one instance I'm
trying to be short here I'll give it to
avenus though it's a clever way of
trying to distance themselves from the
dumpster fire that was 1844 to 63 but it
doesn't get Ellen White Off The Hook as
a false
prophet so what kind of stuff did she
predict or did she predict at all no she
provided Enlightenment to you know what
she would say is first and foremost is
that anything that she provided should
not be held above the Bible everything
she did was to help enhance our
understanding and belief of the Bible
because if you if you take her writings
away you still have the Bible first and
foremost that everything is based upon
and outright lies or ignorance first he
said that Ellen White Never predicted
anything did you catch that Matt asked
what sort of things was she predicting
or was she predicting at all to which he
said with they Stone Cold stare no yeah
we just saw how that is false numerous
times in part one and what I just showed
previously she predicted the return of
Christ would be in 1849 did she set that
date formally no but she claimed to have
a vision supporting such that's worse
that's the bearing of God name God's
name falsely you're not just setting a
date you're claiming God confirmed to me
that that date is correct that's worse
she predicted that the end times people
of God would be identified in part as
those who wash each other's feet and
greet one another with the Holy
kiss even though they would later go on
to publish in numerous publishing arms
of the organization why they don't
practice the holy kiss anymore she
predicted that dairy products would
begin to become more and more unsanitary
and dangerous to consume so that guy's
either misinformed ignorant or lying but
then we got the Lesser light to the
greater light thing that Ellen White
simply functioned to to point people to
the Bible and without her writings the
Bible still stands yeah this sounds nice
except as I already showed she is the
infallible interpreter that uplifts the
normative character of scripture you
supposedly can't understand the Bible
correctly without them to guide you
that's what is meant by she points you
to the Bible her writings can't stand
without the Bible but the Bible can't be
properly understood without her writings
it is a package deal now I have shown
this a lot of times but this is from the
Seventh Adventist believe fundamental
beliefs book which is the official
exposition of their 28 fundamental
beliefs in the chapter on Ellen White
they cite SDA Pioneer Uriah Smith from
an issue of the church's paper the
review and Herald and notice how he
describes how Ellen White functions
quote one illustration may help to set
this matter in a still clearer light
suppose we are about to start upon a
voyage the owner of the vessel gives us
a book of directions telling us that it
contains instructions sufficient for our
whole journey and that if we will heed
them we shall reach in safety our Port
of destination setting sale we open our
book to learn its contents we find that
its author lays down general principles
to govern us in our voyage and instructs
us as far as practicable touching the
various contingencies that may arise
till the end budy also tells us that
latter part of our journey will be
especially Peril and that features of
the Coast are Ever Changing by reason of
quicksands and tempests but for this
part of the journey says he I have
provided you a pilot who will meet you
and give you such directions as the
surrounding circumstances and dangers
may require and to him you must give
heed with these directions we roach the
perilous time specified and the pilot
according to promise appears but some of
the crew as he offers his Services rise
up against him we have have the original
book of directions say they and that is
enough for us we stand upon that and
that alone we want nothing of you who
now heed that original book of
directions those who reject the pilot or
those who receive him as that book
instructs them judge ye close
quote Yeah so not exactly how the
gentleman describes her as simply an
optional supplement or enhancement to
the Bible if one so chooses the owner of
the vessel is supposed to be God and he
gives a book of instructions for the
voyage of Life the Bible within that
book they find that toward the end of
their Voyage there will be perilous
times aka the end times which is why God
has provided a what a pilot which is
Ellen White and to the pilot we are to
give heed but some of the crew like
these gentlemen that Matt is
interviewing they rise up and say things
like we have the Bible that's enough for
us the Bible and the Bible alone to
which Smith rhetorically adds asks well
who's actually yielding to the book of
instructions the ones that reject the
pilot or those that learned by reading
that book that God would send this pilot
in the end and one needs to submit to
them now this is obviously a badly
circular argument one can't understand
the Bible without the infallible
interpreter but in the analogy they read
the Bible to learn about the pilot that
God would allegedly send in the end
times well how could you know that
you're correct about that without the
pilot to tell you you are correct cor
see what I'm saying we heard not too
long ago from the pastor of kenor SDA
Church how he's so glad that God gave
the SDA Church Ellen White because
without her we'd never be able to see
the SDA teaching about the mark of the
beast and the Sunday law in the Bible
alone and I'm so glad we have the spirit
of Prophecy amen I'm so glad the lord
gave us a prophet not only he gave us
his word but the prophet made it clear
without the spirit of Prophecy I don't
know how I would have ever been able to
ear these things from the word of
God that's an honest recognition that's
how she functions you'd never come to
those two beliefs for example without
Ellen White the point being this is
modern current upto-date official SDA
teaching it's not new it was around when
these gentlemen had this discussion it's
not hidden it's not secret it isn't
obscure it is by the book Seventh Day
Adventist teaching some vindictive time
traveler who was mad at your church was
like ha I'll ruin them and they invent
time travel and they go back and
convince Ellen White to become you know
a juggler or something instead and not a
prophetess you're still you and you
still believe what you
believe everything we be believe is
based on the Bible the core beliefs of
our church come from the Bible I think
she helped us provide some understanding
for some of those beliefs but they're
not her beliefs those are biblical
beliefs yeah again so these gentlemen
are either ignorant which is entirely
possible or they are lying and they're
not being forthright I could feel the
tension in that room from my own place
of dwelling another regular source that
I site from constantly former General
Conference president GI Butler speaking
about this exact thing in what led up to
the 1919 controversy he stated quote our
position on the testimonies is like the
Keystone to the arch take that out and
there's no logical stopping Place till
all the special truths of the message
are gone our enemies and the master they
serve realize this but some of our
people are so blind they do not nothing
is Sher than this that the message and
the Visions belong together and stand or
fall together close quote so if Ellen
Falls so does adventism because she is
one of the pillars folks you have to
notice the way Adventists will use
language I'm not saying they're always
being knowingly de you know deceptive or
deceivers Etc but the gentleman said all
of their teachings are based on the
Bible right but not solely derived from
such they will tell you this pre-earth
great controversy origin story is
biblical but there's nothing about it in
the Bible but then when you ask for the
support for for example when you talk
about um show me that uh that that
Lucifer rebelled becoming Satan because
he was jealous of Jesus being exalted
and attacked the Ten Commandments and a
war started over the Ten Commandments
and Lucifer claiming they're not fair
and can't be kept and Angels don't need
to keep them show me that in the Bible
you're going to get pointed a single
verse here and there like that there was
war in
heaven yeah so it's like a movie how
it's based on a true story but oh they
include a bunch of added details to
spice it up for film but they're not
actually there in the actual
history they don't contradict the
storyline they just enhance it and give
these extra details
folks you would never be able to come to
the conclusions they do on numerous
teachings without Ellen White's alleged
Divine insights we've listened to
multiple SDA pastors and leaders that
recognize this and just explicitly State
as much so Matt you were badly lied to
here and yes I say lie because some of
the stuff is
inexcusable you're a pastor in the SDA
church and you're saying she never
predicted anything for
real adventism can stand without Ellen
White yeah
right I know many SD like to think this
and tell people this but no folks
there's an objectively correct answer
here this is another case of
slipperiness Ellen White predicted all
sorts of things by claiming to be shown
stuff in Vision confirming things other
people
predicted a lot of Adventists will act
like this gives her some sort of
immunity because she wasn't the one
doing the original prediction but no
this is sophistry and semantic games it
is a prediction when someone else says
it and then you claim to be given a
vision confirming the prediction signing
on to it but it's actually worse than
the person making the original
prediction because Ellen attached God's
name to numerous ones violating the
third commandment in the process she
bore God's name falsely every time that
she claimed God showed her something
that was then demonstrated to be false
you were anticipating my next question
so then what is the value provided I
think there was a clarifying role I
think there was a pastoral role you know
if you look at some of the things that
Ellen White um wrote um some of them
were visions and some of those were
visions that I mean I really I really
think that they helped to form like
adventism within The Crucible of that
experience those years of flux that the
church was in before they were really
formed as a
church ah catch that he called The
Forgotten years the church was formerly
the church right so trying to cut that
period off entirely distanced from it
yeah slippery Matt like I told you this
movement is slippery that's how I would
describe the the teachings we looked at
that back in part
one um and gave people Faith to say hey
God's not abandoned us he's like he's
leading us you know one of her Visions
was a vision of people climbing on this
narrow precipice and and and relying on
uh faith and relying on scripture to to
get through a difficult you know uh to
to reach a difficult Summit you know so
it's those kinds of things like hey guys
God's not left us alone let's you know
Adventists even in the context of Ellen
White's presence and her voice in the
church were were people of the book oh
brother more watering down to the facts
what he referred to was the path Vision
we've talked about and looked at this
numerous times it wasn't simply a
message of encouragement climbing up a
big precipice like it was some halftime
speech of encouragement for the team it
may have been encouragement for some
people but it was veiled in a threat she
claimed that anyone that rejected the
fanaticism of the little flock and the
refusal to accept that they were wrong
in 1844 fell off the path down into the
wicked world that God had rejected a bit
of a long one here but we got to read
the whole thing notice quote while
praying at the family altar the Holy
Ghost fell on me and I seem to be rising
higher and higher far above the Dark
World I turned to look for the people in
the world but could not find them when a
voice said to me look again and look a
little higher at this I raised my eyes
and saw a straight and narrow path cast
up high above the world on this path the
Advent people were traveling to the city
which was at the farther end of the path
they had a bright light set up behind
them at the first end of the path which
an angel told me was the Midnight Cry
this light Shone All Along The Path and
gave light for their feet so might not
stumble and if they kept their eyes
fixed on Jesus who was just before them
leading them to the city they were safe
but soon some grew weary and they said
the city was a great way off and they
expected to have entered it before then
Jesus would encourage them by raising
his glorious right arm and from his arm
came a glorious light which waved over
the Advent band and they shouted
Hallelujah others rashly denied the
light behind them and said that it was
not God that had led them out out so far
the light behind them went out leaving
their feet in perfect darkness and they
stumbled and got their eyes off the mark
and lost sight of Jesus and fell off the
path down in the dark and Wicked World
below it was just as impossible for them
to get on the path again and go to the
city as all the Wicked World which God
had rejected they fell all the way along
the path one after another until we
heard the voice of God like many Waters
which gave us the day and hour of
Jesus's coming close quote Yeah so
encouragement only in a tertiary sense
to the main thrust which was a
threatening which was that they were
exclusively God's people Christians that
rejected millerism were already
considered to be a part of the wicked
world that God had rejected and those
within the little flock that came to
their senses and realized they were
being misled they supposedly fell off
the path and joined the wicked world
that God had rejected and not just that
but but it was impossible for those in
the Wicked World to get onto the path
only the little flock was on the path
those millerites that refused to accept
that they were wrong in 1844 which was
perfectly consistent with the idea that
the time of Salvation was up the door
was shut and only those on the path were
going to make it into the city of God
yet this belief changed and the Wicked
World actually wasn't rejected by God
and people could still be saved yeah not
exactly clarifying light from heaven
when another vision after this corrects
the previous one both of which are
supposed to be from God who isn't the
author of
confusion to try and boil this down to
Simply encouragement when it was a scare
tactic false vision is not only
dishonest but it's not painting the
whole picture and simply repeating over
and over that Adventists are a people of
the book doesn't make it so it doesn't
mean you're handling the book
correctly adventism is a people of the
book so long as it Accords with alen
White's commentary and
visions and the leadership knows this
folks it's then disseminated down to the
pews already being distilled and
filtered through all of that where
assertions are just made about the Bible
and what it's being and what the Bible
is saying Adventists then trust their
leaders and trust that they are correct
in their thinking that adventism is
solely based on the
Bible and this isn't to say that people
haven't wielded her as a as an authority
on equal level or greater than the Bible
and you mean outside critics of
adventism no no I'm saying that within
within adventism there have absolutely
been times and places where people have
elevated her position wrongfully on par
or above and and every time we would
just be like no that's that's a misuse
and I think one of my favorite and most
endearing things about Ellen White and
her role in the church is that she's
she's actually very clear that that's
not the way she ever saw herself she
said on multiple occasions don't quote
me like don't say Mrs White said this or
sister white said that like don't quote
me until you can actually stand on a
thus sayith The Lord Oh you mean the
general conference which Ellen White
said is the highest Authority on earth
when in session and in session they
state that her writings are divinely
inspired in correcting of inaccurate
interpretations of the Bible or Ellen
White herself who said quote the Holy
Ghost is the author of the scriptures
and of the spirit of Prophecy speaking
about her writings these are not to be
twisted and turned to mean what may and
may want them to mean to carry out man's
ideas and sentiments to carry forward
man's schemes at all hazards close quote
the idea that it's a fringe minority of
people who have aant abused Ellen White
doesn't track with
reality furthermore she plainly said the
Holy Spirit authored both her writings
and the Bible trying to downplay this to
say there's still a hierarchy between
the two it's just more sophistry in word
games no the Holy Spirit if the Holy
Spirit authored it it carries the same
weight doesn't matter if you say well
one's canonical one's not canonical
that's a whole different discussion
you're saying the source for both is the
same which means it carries the same
level of authority stop playing word
games there is a common defense to this
that you can expect to hear though we
find an example of it in his book Allen
white Under Fire where Dr Jud Lake
claims that the issue in this area is
that the critics of adventism operate in
a false binary he writes quote ratl
Kelly and dowy each make the same
assumption if Ellen White's writings are
inspired like the Bible writers her
Authority is equal with that of the
Bible writers and therefore it is on the
same level as scripture if this is true
then Adventists are inconsistent when as
dowy argued they deny that her works are
on par with the scriptures the problem
with dy's argument is that he created a
false dilemma by limiting the issues to
one of only two choices Mrs whites
having no inspiration or having one
equal to the Bibles there is a third
option he failed to recognize Ellen
White's inspiration equals that of the
Bible writers but her prophetic
Authority is limited because of the
nature of its relationship to the Bible
close quote this is to say that when
it's pointed out that her writings must
carry the same amount of authority as
the Bible since both are authored by God
they claim that this is a false
dichotomy and there's a third option she
can be equal in Inspiration but not
carry the same level of
authority well how then is she lesser in
Authority you might ask he goes on to
explain where he writes quote in light
of this Biblical teaching the
manifestation of the prophetic gift
after the closing of the Canon that is a
genuine Revelation from God doesn't
compromise or challenge the authority of
the Canon rather genuine postc canonical
prophecy submits itself to be tested and
evaluated by the Canon it always
harmonizes with the Canon and like the
non-canonical prophets never adds new
doctrine to previous Revelation close
quote Yeah the investigative judgment is
absolutely a new doctrine acting like
it's been in the scriptures this whole
time yet no one saw it until the 19th
century is a cope but secondly he says
that she's lesser in Authority because
she is non-canonical making her subject
to the test of scripture yet like we saw
earlier the organization simultaneously
tells us that we can't properly
understand the scriptures without
consulting her commentary on such to
help us understand the normative
character of it which creates a circular
defense when they are telling us that we
can't understand the without her
writings which is the official position
there's no getting out of this
predicament if the Holy Spirit authored
both the Bible and her writings then
both would carry the same Authority
regardless of if one is canonical and
the other isn't and that's because of
the source behind both of them God
himself the thing that makes the Canon
unique is not that it's Revelation from
God with more Authority than other
Revelations from God but it's
Transcendent quality meaning canonical
scripture is authoritative Beyond a
localized region or time period which is
what makes it unique to other
Revelations that God gave in human
history like with localized prophets in
the first century their Authority died
when they died whereas Jeremiah Malachi
Ezekiel Etc their Authority lives on
despite their death Ellen White's
Authority is not treated like a
localized Prophet it is treated like a
canonical one as we will see in a little
bit from her own mouth with regards to
him saying Ellen White said to not quote
her until one can say a thus sayeth the
Lord yes and Justin she claimed her
books are barricaded by a thus sayeth
the Lord I site this all the time
selected messages book three page 122
quote how many have read carefully
Patriarchs and Prophets great
controversy and Desire of Ages I wish
all to understand that my confidence in
the light that God has given stands firm
because I know that the holy spirit's
power magnified the truth and made it
honorable saying this is the way walk ye
in it in my books the truth is stated
barricaded by a thus saith the Lord the
Holy Spirit traced these truths upon my
heart and mind as indelibly as the law
was traced by the Finger of God upon the
tables of stone which are now in the ark
to be brought forth in the great day
when sentence will be pronounced against
every evil seducing science produced by
the father of Lies close quote
furthermore she also claimed quote the
testimonies are unread and unappreciated
God has spoken to you light has been
shining from his word and from the
testimonies and both have been slided
and disregarded the result is apparent
in the lack of Purity and devotion and
Earnest Faith Among Us close
quote she also claimed that it's Satan's
plan to weaken people's faith in her
writings doing so will lead to doubting
the Bible outright rejecting the SDA
pillar doctrines and ultimately leading
a person to predition quote it is
Satan's plan to weaken the faith of
God's people in the testimony
next follows skepticism in regard to the
vital points of our faith the pillars of
our position then doubt as to the holy
scriptures and then the downward march
to predition when the testimonies which
were once believed are doubted and given
up Satan knows the deceived ones will
not stop at this and he redoubles his
efforts till he launches them into open
Rebellion which becomes incurable and
ends in destruction close
quote and that wasn't a one-off claim
again in quote I know your danger if you
lose confidence in the testimonies you
will drift away from Bible truth I've
been fearful that many would take a
questioning doubting position and in my
distress for your souls I would warn you
how many will heed the warning as you
now hold the testimonies should one be
given crossing your track correcting
your errors would you feel at perfect
Liberty to accept or reject any part or
the whole that which you will be least
inclined to receive is the very part
most needed God and Satan never work in
co-partnership the testimonies either
bear the signate of God or that of Satan
close quote right they bear the mark of
Satan indeed notice she chastised
Adventists for thinking they can
disregard or ignore her testimonies
which are warnings from God himself to
the SDA Church the downplaying of Ellen
White by people like Justin is born out
of not having read her widely enough to
see why the people he claims are abusing
her are saying what they are
he is either unaware of this plethora of
statements or he's being dishonest and I
don't think people like him really
understand the great controversy
worldview that they have been equipped
with we can't even know what is a true
thus sayeth the Lord without Ellen White
to infallibly guide us in understanding
the Bible so says the organization she's
the pilot that we need to submit
to um and the thus say of the Lord was
the word of scripture yes so then why
have a prophet
I think the role of the prophet
prophetess in in in this context is just
to point us back to what the text had
already said and I think that this is
somewhat in keeping with the roles of of
prophets in in the Old Testament and
other places where it's like there is an
established word and the people of God
have gone away from the established word
and the prophet or prophetes is is
pointing back to the word no come back
come back to God be faithful to his word
and and I see that this is the role that
Ellen White played for for us
yes excellent question Matt but no Mr
glass's beard is wrong as we just saw
Ellen White said her books are
barricaded by a thus sayeth the Lord
that's not the Bible Justin said her
purpose was to point us back to what the
text already says no this is not true
like we saw with GI Butler Ellen White
gives special insights into things no
one else has ever seen before and
allegedly gives the SDA Church the
theological God Particle to truly
understand the Bible and the mind of God
the great controversy worldview does not
come from the
Bible we saw in part one and I've shown
this Source I don't even know how many
times herb Douglas SDA Theologian in
Ministry magazine said that the great
controversy theme was given to the SDA
Church his words given not discovered
you won't find anything in the Bible
about a pre-earth exaltation of Jesus
before the creation of the earth which
made Lucifer jealous this then leading
to him rebelling against in the Ten
Commandments starting a controversy
where God is now on trial having to
vindicate himself from these accusations
of one of his
creatures because none of that is
biblical it comes strictly from Ellen
White yet that is the core of the avenus
Paradigm that their entire system of
theology is filtered
through it informs for them why Jesus
came what he came to do what the cross
was about
Etc furthermore they entire doctrine of
present truth undermines this idea that
Ellen just points one back to what the
Bible already
says does the bible say that Jesus would
return in 1849 like we saw her endorse
through her vision
earlier does the bible say that the holy
kiss is one of the identifying marks of
God's last day people which Ellen
endorsed in
Vision does the bible say that the time
of salvation for the lost ended in the
1840s
does it say that Lucifer tried to
inquire an interview with Jesus after he
began his Rebellion before the you know
great controversy really kicked off with
its first conflict and
battle does the Bible say like we saw in
part one that Jesus Took on an Angelic
nature to try and save Angels prior to
incarnating as a
man I'm sorry but the SDA church is
stuck having to acknowledge that they
don't just believe the
Bible they think that because they have
a proof text they can cite that
justifies them using the verse in any
way they see fit and it's ultimately
however Ellen did and the organization
yields to that I want to come back to uh
the question you asked which is
essentially why a
prophet um let me flip that around and
just ask the question why not a prophet
it all throughout scripture from the
beginning to the end of of of of
canonical scripture and and I'm clear
I'm saying that with intentionality
because the writings of Ellen White are
not canonical and there's never never
been an attempt um on the part of the
church to to make them canonical or to
to have them be like an extra biblical
source of authoritative like the Bible
is our is our only Creed that was like
one of the foundational principles of of
that we're people of the book um but the
Bible itself says says that God doesn't
do anything without revealing it to the
prophets like there's this sense all
through scripture that the gift of
Prophecy was something that was that was
like a norm in in the way that the
people of God heard from from God and uh
so I'm I guess I'm I'd throw the
question back not in a not in a
mean-spirited way but just to say like
hey guys like do we believe do we
believe that God still
speaks yes God still speaks and it's in
his fallible inherent word not through
false prophets I have all the prophets I
need contained in the Holy scriptures
and God speaks to me every time I read
them and if I want to hear them audibly
I just read it out loud the point being
the answer to his question is simple why
not a prophet because Jesus is the great
prophet priest and king and the prophets
like that were until John the Apostle
the last of those prophets but he said
the writings of Ellen White are not
canonical and the SDA church has never
tried to make her in
Authority does that jive with what I
showed earlier folks
sources from the highest Authority
within the organization the GC no it
doesn't at least as it pertains to her
being an authority it's literally in the
fundamental belief itself guys quote
this gift is an identifying Mark of the
remnant church and we believe it was
manifested in the ministry of Ellen
White her writings speak with prophetic
Authority and provide Comfort guidance
instruction and correction to the church
they also make clear that the Bible is
the standard by which all teaching and
experience must be tested close quote so
it's Ellen White's writings that tell us
that the Bible is the standard you know
this because her writings that speak
with prophetic Authority tell you this
so the guy outright lied when he said
the SD church has never tried to make
her an authority like what it's
literally in the fundamental belief guy
H as to her not being canonical this is
the Catch 22 the SDA church has been in
since Ellen White died first notice what
SDA historian Michael Campbell notes
about this in his book 1919 quote in
many ways Adventist after her death
continued functioning as if they still
had a living Prophet articles were
reprinted or gleaned from her
unpublished writings as if she were
still alive one final book manuscript
appeared about Old Testament history
prophets and Kings whose last two
chapters of which were pieced together
from previously unpublished articles and
manuscripts this completed the five
volume conflict of the ages series
spanning The Cosmic controversy between
Christ and Satan from the birth of sin
until its final eradication at the last
judgment it would not be until the 1919
Bible Conference that Adventist thought
leaders seriously wrestled with what it
meant to no longer have a living
prophetic voice there were significant
ramifications for how the denomination
would view her writings as a consequence
the reality of living without a prophit
loomed large in Adventist Minds at this
time close quote and this disposition by
Adventist that he's referring to was
because of things that she herself said
quote abundant light has been given to
our people in these last last days
whether or not my life is spared my
writings will constantly speak and their
work will go forward as long as time
shall last my writings are kept on file
in the office and even though I should
not live these words that have been
given to me by the Lord will still have
life and will speak to the people close
quote and this quote physically I've
always been as a broken vessel and yet
in my old age the Lord continues to move
upon me by his holy spirit to write the
most important books that have ever come
before the churches and the world the
lord is evidencing what he can do
through weak vessels the life that he
spares I will use to his glory and when
he sees fit to let me rest his messages
shall be of even more vital force than
when the frail instrumentality through
whom they were delivered was living
close quote Yeah that isn't how a
localized Prophet functioned which is
why Adventists like these gentlemen are
stuck in a catch 22 when they try and
say that she isn't seen as canonical
they may claim that she's not canonical
and that she doesn't add to scripture
but the organization doesn't simply
teach that Ellen White had the New
Testament gift of Prophecy they may use
that language to try and make it seem
less innocuous but the facts and
practical way in which she functions are
evidence to the contrary she functions
like a canonical Prophet even if they
say she's not
canonical so I like doing these reaction
videos because I think it's beneficial
for Christians to see uh just how hard
it can be to pinpoint what adventism
actually teaches whether knowingly or
unknowingly Adventists have been given a
certain way to say and phrase things
typically based on how the organization
has taught them the language and Buzz
phrases have gone through numerous
revisionary processes to make it more
plausibly deniable like we saw back in
part one with fundamental belief number
18 where they used to claim that Ellen
White is a continuing and authoritative
source of Truth the belief now says like
we just saw she speaks with prophetic
Authority
are we really supposed to believe they
don't still teach or believe that she is
a continuing and authoritative source of
truth of course not they've just worded
it in such a way now that gives less it
makes it more innocuous it keeps the
heat off the organization and it makes
it appear like they're just another
Protestant or Evangelical Group which is
what they want to be the case but they
are not I say this a lot and I'll
continue doing so as more and more
people are waking up to this adventism
is its own unique thing
with their own unique Mission and
message that only they have we read in
the lesson on page 106 Central to
Mission God's mission is the message
God's message that is the gospel the
message the author writes in a real
sense is the mission the message is the
mission we must never lose sight of our
special calling and Mission special
calling and Mission special calling and
Mission which is to Proclaim to a Lost
World The Hope found in the Everlasting
gospel as well as to warn the world of
what will one day come upon it the
author goes on to say it is urgent that
the gospel be proclaimed and the serious
news about Satan's strategies be exposed
and that is exactly what the Three
Angels messages and our mission are all
about so we are now going to be taking a
deeper dive into these Three Angels
messages which are the the last message
we what we call present truth gospel
present truth gospel present truth
gospel the gospel in its present truth
form to be proclaimed to the last day
inhabitants of planet Earth they do not
share in the same missions singular
Mission and message as the Christian
church I've shown this from their own
fundamental beliefs book their website
their prophetes and numerous other
primary sources from the 19th to the
21st
centuries they think it's their duty to
warn Christians specifically Christians
to come join them or they won't be
prepared for the second
coming you'll only be prepared for
Jesus's soon return if you join the SDA
church and accept the great controversy
worldview and its
Theology and Adventist especially those
in positions of leadership they need to
be more forthright about this not try
and play both sides of the field it's
dishonest and the avenus propheus
actually spoke against such where she
wrote quote then Brethren use wisely the
precious light that God has given
presenting it to the people in the
meekness and gentleness of Christ meet
the Prejudice of the people with an
invitation such as Philip gave Nathaniel
come and see
say if seventh day Adventists have the
truth and can prove it so from the
Oracles of God you do not wish to be
found fighting against God we are to be
bodies of light proclaiming Christ and
his love to the people and presenting
all our doctrines in the true relation
to this important theme we shall have to
meet people as full of hatred to our
work as were the priests and rulers in
the days of Christ to his work it is our
duty however to diffuse light in every
direction and lay out in clear lines
what the sinner must do in order to
obtain eternal life close quote and that
isn't what these gentlemen did here they
blurred the lines whether knowingly or
unknowingly and put the SDA light under
a bushel in embarrassment which is par
for the course with the Neo Adventists
that have sought to reimagine and
Rebrand adventism as something that it
is not anyways if you like what we're
doing here smash that like button
subscribe so you can be updated next
time we go live and until next time May
Christ richly bless you in the grace and
peace won by him and his vicarious death
on the cross for Sinners Hallelujah and
Marin ho to
apostate did he say
that come on man